it's not inspiration its concentration
more you know and it's it's to do with
developing skills of concentration and
and I think that's something which is
one of the few things I think about
about being a writer that you get better
at with time you know there are things
that you that you would perhaps don't
get better at you know I mean energy is
something which maybe declines but I
think concentration focus the ability to
shut out the extraneous and focus on
what you're doing I think you know the
more you do it the better you get at it
that's I think that's true and I think
it's also true that and I think I've
heard other writers say too that when
you write you in a way right out of what
you think of as your best self you know
that the part of you that is lacking in
foibles and weaknesses and egos egotism
and you know vanities so on you're just
trying to really say something as
truthful as you can out of the best that
you have in you you know and and so I
think and somehow the physical act of
doing it is the only way you have of
having access to that self you know it's
when you're not physically writing the
key you don't have the key to that door
you know and and but when you get in a
certain speaking for me when I get into
you know I get into a state of properly
concentrated attention then I do think
that that is probably I think about is
my best self the self that does that and
and I mean I wish I had access to it the
rest of the time it's at least I at
least I can find my way to it through
that it's not inspiration I think
inspiration is nonsense actually every
so often I mean like one day in 20 or
something you will have a day when the
work seems to just flow out of you and
and you feel lucky when you feel you and
often surprised and you don't quite know
why it is working like that and on days
like that it's easy to believe in in a
kind of inspiration but most of the time
it's not like that you know most of the
time it's I mean I wish there were more
of those days
most the time it's it's a lot slower and
more exploratory and more a process of
discovering you know what you have to do
then just simply have it arrive like a
like a flame over your head you know so
I do think it's it's to do with
concentration not into it's to do with
paying attention and I think the the the
business of writing has a great deal of
it is is is the business of paying
attention to your characters to the
world they live in to the story you have
to tell but just a kind of deep
attention and out of that if you pay
attention properly the story will tell
you what it needs